[موسيقى]
انا طبيب امارس مهنتي في ضواحي باريس
منذ نحو عام اتعاطى الكوكايين يوميا يصل
الكوكايين حتى باب المنزل في باريس يكفي
بعث رساله مشفره الى احد البائعين وبعد
ساعه او اقل يكون الطلب حاضرا من السهل
الحصول عليه فالتجار كثر على تطبيقات
كتليجرام في بعض الاحيان يقدمون عروضا
لقاء كل ثلاثه جرامات يعطونك غراما اضافيا
بسعر 70 يورو للغرام بين الطبقه المتوسطه
في فرنسا وفي اوروبا عموما في 2021 جرب
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون اوروبي
الكوكايين لمره واحده على الاقل رقم اعلى
باربعه اضعاف عن المسجل قبل 20 عاما اذا
تحول لون المسحوق الى الازرق فهذا يعني
انه كوكين في مطار اورلي في فرنسا يتم
توقيف مئات الاشخاص وبحوزتهم الكوكايين
اثار ازرق اللون اذا هذا كوكايين هيا
سترافقنا ياتي العديد من المهربين من
جويانا الفرنسيه في امريكا الجنوبيه
يبتلعون كبسولات محشوه بالكوكايين كي
ينقلوها في احشائهم صور الاشعه هذه لاحد
المهربين قبل خروجهم من مطار العاصمه
هنا وهنا توجد كبسولات
في بعض الاحيان يبتلعون الكبسولات تحت
التهديد او لدفع الديون انهم اناس في محنه
واظن ان معظمهم ضحايا
الفقر فكويان يدفع الشباب الى اعمال تخالف
القانون كالتهريب لكنما ينقله البشر ليس
الا جزءا بسيطا من تجاره الكوكايين 90% من
هذه التجاره غير الشرعيه تعبر المحيط
الاطلسي مخباه داخل حاويات شرعيه لنقل
الموز او السكر
ميناء انت ويب في بلجيكا مدخل رئيسي
للمسحوق الابيض في عام 2022 وحده صدر هنا
110,000
ترون الكوكايين في اسفل الحاويه
اما بقيه الحاويه فملئ بالموز
يقدر المختصون ان خمسه الى عشره في المئه
فقط من الكوكايين المتداول يضبط من قبل
السلطات
في العقد الاول من القرن الحالي وضع
اباطره المخدرات في امريكا اللاتينيه
القاره الاوروبيه هدفا لهم مدر عليهم
ارباحا بعشرات المليارات من الدولارات
تبدا رحله الكوكايين عند منحدرات الجبال
في كولومبيا وبيرو وبوليفيا في منطقتيمبو
الكولومبيه يعتبر نبات الكوكا اشهر
المحاصيل على الاطلاق فقد فشلت السلطات
هناك في حربها ضد المخدرات في هذا البلد
لا يتجاوز الحد الادنى للاجور اليوميه
سبعه دولارات فيما يكسب من يعمل في الكوكا
خمسه اضعاف ذلك في كل مره يموت مزارع بسبب
زراعه الكوكا يظهر مزارعان في مكانه لماذا
لان الاستثمارات تكاد تكون مفقوده تماما
في بلدنا
الاستثمار في الكوكايين فيوفر ارباحا لا
نظير لها في ارضه بامريكا الجنوبيه يساوي
الكيلو الف دولار اما في اوروبا فيباع
بخمسه وثلاثين الف يورو
ويتضاعف السعر حاله خروج البضاعه من
الموانئ وتقسيمها الى قطع صغيره
تتقاسم المنظمات الاجراميه الاوروبيه هذه
السوق المربحه في هولندا وبلجيكا تنشط
موركو مافيا وفي جنوب ايطاليا منظمه
الاجراميه وغيرها من العصابات من
الالبانيه او صربيه او كسوفيه لتسيير
مصالحها لا تتورع الاصابات عن فعل اي شيء
حاولت اختطاف وزير العدل البلجيكي في
العام الماضي ويشتبه بان موكرو مافيا تقف
وراء مقتل صحفيا وقبله محامي في هولندا
تجاره الكوكايين العالميات تنظم من خلال
شبكات ضخمه واسعه تعمل يدا بيد لم تعد
جماعات متنافسه وهذا امر خطير للغايه
لانها تتمتع بالمرونه ولديها افكار مبتكره
وتحسن تطبيقها
افكار مبتكره وانتشار على مستوى العالم في
نهايه تشرين الثاني نوفمبر الماضي نشرت
شرطه دبي صورا لحمله مداهمات واسعه نفذتها
بالتعاون مع الشرطه الاوروبيه
الاعتقالات شملت ايضا مدن اوروبيه وطالت
في مجمل 50 مشتبها به ونتج عنها تفكيك
سوبر كارتيل واحده من اوسع الشبكات
الاجراميه التي كانت تسيطر على ثنف تهريب
الكوكايين الى اوروبا امام تفشي افتي
المسحوق الابيض ليس امام السلطات
الاوروبيه حل سوى شن حرب لالقاء القبض على
الرؤوس التي